Speaker 2: Hi, David, how are you doing? I'm
doing well. So I wanted to touch on this topic,
given the Democratic leadership you had Steny
Hoyer and Jim Clyburn. And there tends to be this
conventional wisdom that progressive Democrats
can only win in districts like a on a Pressley's,
and that if we were to turn the Democratic Party
toward a more progressive direction that we would,
that we would lose nationwide. And there is a
piece on Jacobin about this, given the fact that
rural voters have really turned toward the
Republican Party. And the reality is that in 2022,
I have seen a candidate that has run
a totally grassroots, people powered
congressional bid. And that's Derrick Marshall.
He's running in the 23rd Congressional District,
down in the high desert of Southern California.
And I was just curious if you've been keeping
tabs on the midterms and if there's any.
That had, like struck your eye as candidates
running in rural areas, places that are maybe
unconventional so that we can continue to fight
for issues that are affecting people who are maybe
most disproportionately affected by
poverty and by the day to day struggle.
Speaker 1: I can't say specifically that there's
progressive rural candidates that I would be able
to sort of like recommend to anybody. But my
recommendation would be if you are in a rural
area, find out who's running because my capacity
on the show to know about every candidate running
everywhere is is very limited in my ability to
interview all of them is also very limited. But
we're going to have very soon. I was interviewed
by Farron Cousins in Las Vegas recently, and he's
going to be publishing an interview. We did sort
of about exactly this issue, which is how do you
deal with figuring out what races to get involved
in? And I'm going to be talking about it on the
show as well. But but you know, and unfortunately,
it's beyond the scope of my show to tell everybody
who to support, et cetera, et cetera. But there's
no shortage of great candidates out there,
and it's great that you're paying attention.
Speaker 2: I'm thinking,
Speaker 1: all right there. There we go.
Very, very important message for sure.